my name is Anthony's go pats I'm a
professor of nuclear engineering at the
University of South Carolina and I'm
going to talk to you today a bit about a
diversity theory and what that is and
sort of this is sort of a non-standard
diversity talk in the sense that this is
takes a more quantitative and empirical
approach to diversity than you might
normally see another in a diversity top
so if you uh if you're interested in
stalking me on the Internet here are
some more information about me just to
tell you so I'm a Python software
foundation fellow the sounding treasurer
and former board member of Nome focus
step down from that role a few years ago
my research group is called eggs I'm it
but if you've heard of me on the
internet it's probably through this like
wacky Python shell bash hybrid project
called conch or through this book called
effective computation of physics that I
wrote with Kitty huff okay so that's
what I am you can go and find me
elsewhere alright so when I was
preparing for this talk and sort of
mulling over it for the whole summer I
started with a few motivating questions
about diversity and diversity issues and
so I just thought I'd put those up
initially so that we could sort of start
from the same page so the first one is
that if diversity is such an important
topic why don't we have a rigorous
mathematical approach to it right for
everything else that we do especially
for people in this room we have a
rigorous mathematical formulation so why
don't we have one for diversity if we
think diversity is such an important
topic what is the science of diversity
is there a science that exists that we
can go and borrow from you know maybe
maybe other people have thought about
this and given that can we engineer
equitable systems right they think this
is the purpose of studying diversity in
this way is to design equitable systems
and if so how do we do it and if not why
not and what are the problems so these
are the questions that I started with
so it turns out there is a diversity
theory right if you go to ecology
they've actually had a definition of
diversity since the 1960s so this stuff
isn't even particularly new and if you
look at their definition and sort of the
canonical ecology paper on this stuff
okay they just say information content
may be used as a measure of the
diversity of a many species biological
system so BAM done information equals
diversity we can all go home right not
exactly there's a little more subtle tea
they've been thinking about this in 66
60s but the basic premise is that we can
use information as a as a proxy for
diversity and in particular they kind of
break this down into two components so
they have a gamma component of diversity
that they set equal to an alpha times of
beta and so the Alpha component is if
you take one particular region and you
look at the diversity just within that
sub region that's your alpha and then
that is separate from the diversity
between different regions right so if
you think about this sort of
geographically this is how they break it
down not so bad this has a few
interesting premises and side effects
though so that we can maybe just look at
look at what those are so they they have
some intuitive basic properties of what
they feel like diversity should mean and
from these definitions will go and see
some of the mathematical ramifications
so just to list them off the first one
is that alpha and beta components should
be independent right so that the
diversity of between within the group is
should be separate from the diversity
between groups the same value the same
number if you get the same one number
for diversity that should denote the
exact same amount of diversity if you
were to go and measure the other number
so this means that basically you want
alpha and beta to be measured on the
same scale they're equal equal value
systems and that seems like a reasonable
thing to assume alpha is an average
diversity it's not talking about
individuals it's talking about popular
patience another reasonable assumption
perhaps and then gamma must be
completely determined by alpha and beta
there's no hidden variables in the
system so this is the complete a
description of diversity and then
finally alpha must be less than or equal
to gamma okay pretty reasonable
assumptions it actually took them up
until this decade more or less to kind
of agree that this was the set of
reasonable assumption so there's been a
lot of debate over the past 50 years 60
years but this is what what's happened
so interestingly there are some
repercussions for this so one is that
you can't define gamma as the sum of
alpha and beta it has to be the product
if you take these assumptions if you try
to use this this formulation things
other various of these properties fall
apart there's a lot of debate about why
that is or there was a lot of discussion
about why that is additionally if you
want to use information or entropy as
your diversity it actually can't just be
used directly and so entropy becomes
what this thing that they term a
diversity index that then you adjust to
become the diversity so the alpha or
gamma equals alpha times beta equation
if you just use divert if you just use
entropy directly it doesn't actually
conform to those basic principles so you
have to do something else which means
that your diversity d is actually a
function of entropy H we'll talk about
what that is okay um so there's a few
different notions of what your diversity
index that are common in ecology that
you can look at and they're all
relatively simple so this is paper or
this this is just taken from this one
joost paper here and at the base level
there's this thing called species
richness which is just the sum of your
populations to the zeroth power
which some together which of course just
equals s so the number of groups so this
is just a measure of the total number of
groups or species that you have in your
system and if that is your diversity
index then your diversity d of H is just
equal to H or equal to s in this case
alternatively right since we're talking
about information you could just use the
Shannon entropy which seems like which
is what people did originally so if you
uses Shannon entropy as your diversity
index the the diversity is on just the
exponent of your Shannon entropy so it's
not hard right this is like one
expression in Python it's not a lot of
work and then there are some others
probably the most interesting one is
this rennie entropy which looks a lot
like the Shannon entropy but with this Q
term that we'll talk more about later
and then you know sort of importantly if
you take this as your diversity index or
if you take the rainy entropy as your
diversity index the the diversity as a
function of that is just the same
exponent so not so bad okay so uh
economists talk about diversity in using
the terminology numbers equivalent if
you haven't heard this term before which
I hadn't before diving into this stuff
but numbers equivalent just me and sort
of the total number of effective
elements or if you come from a physics
background it's equivalent to the number
of states that you have and it's
importantly if you have a diversity of
order Q this diversity is of order Q is
what follows our ecologists
representation of gamma equals alpha
times beta so qdh gamma is what's equal
to QD h alpha x qg h beta and so and you
can pick any of those h's that you want
and they all will follow this equation
okay um in the sort of shocking and
particularly interesting fall out of all
of this is that for any of those entropy
measures that we had or any of those
diversity or those those entropy indexes
H that we had on the previous couple
slides ago this very simple expression
falls out so diversity of order Q is
always you can always say it's equal to
the sum of your populations two of two
the cute power and then that some itself
to 1 over 1 minus Q okay and if you go
through for all those diversity index
indices you can show this is actually
discovered through the ren you entropy
which is why the rent you one is
probably the most interesting it also
has some other population implications
so this is pretty cool and so that
really means we just need to pick a
queue right so which q do we use so if
your Q equals 0 we're just back at the
species richness right we're just back
at the total sum the number of
partitions are the number of groups s if
we have a queue less than one we're
disproportionately affecting or we're
disproportionately counting rare species
so if you're interested in like looking
at minority or small small population
groups you would choose a queue less
than one if you choose a Q equal one the
limit of that just falls out to the
exponent of the Shannon entropy like we
had before so that's pretty cool and
then if you take Q greater than one
which you probably wouldn't do in this
context you're disproportionately
sensitive to common species so these are
sort of the bounds of this equation with
respect to Q um oops it's not the next
one yeah okay so i think you know if
you'll if you'll note basically we've
spent the whole time so far talking
about ecology and we haven't actually
mentioned humans at all and so you know
there's this open
and kind of philosophical question of
whether humans are important and we're
just going to take axiomatically that
humans are for the rest of this talk and
if you don't believe that like please
return to the internet so that was the
joke for this talk so you should get the
laughing and now yeah okay so um that
being said how do you given that we're
actually trying to deal with humans not
species of like insects in the tropics
or something you know how do you define
fairness right so we need to pick some
cues so which q do we pick which order
do we don't want to look at and if you
pick q equals one you're actually fair
to individuals individual members of the
of your broader population but if you
want to be fair to each group on its
with respect to each other group you
would pick a queue of 1 over s or 1 over
the number of partitions that you have
and so that's less than 1 and so it's
kind of favoring each group on its own
and if you want to measure if you want
to be fair to both groups and
individuals equally you'd cute choose Q
equals 2 over s not so not so bad if you
have to pick a queue so here are some
ideas i'm not saying which one you
should pick but at least this gives us
an axis on which to analyze things but
i'll note that whoever gets to choose
the partitioning actually has a lot of
power right if you get to sit down and
determine what groups are available or
what buckets people are allowed to fit
in then you have a lot of power and that
actually shows itself in the math here
right it falls out which i think is
pretty cool additionally you could might
think you could get around this by
having people just self-report whatever
group they're in but uh you know you
might not want to do this because then
you it you might want to take this to
its logical constrain because then you
just end up with so many buckets that
your s is huge and so you might have say
well maybe we should have some minimum
population threshold before we count a
bucket but you're back at the same
problem because who
to decide that but that that threshold
and so that also falls out right like
there was this case in the UK about ten
years ago right where a Jedi was
declared like a religion because they
met the maximum threshold of people and
you know not to say anything against the
jedis but like there's clearly some
threshold issue going on here so with
their senses so that again falls out
which is kind of neat okay so I think
the problem with diversity really is
that it's not a sufficient measure for
what we're trying to achieve and 22 will
prove this sort of through a
counterexample right so just saying if
diversity were sufficient if diversity
were enough to sort of address all the
problems that we cared about then
diverse collections would always be
preferable to a homogenous collections
and I don't think you need to go further
than the definition of empire to realize
that that's not necessarily a true
statement alright so if you look at the
formal definition of empire it says that
in empires and aggregate of Nations
ruled basically by a single government
and so demp ire is by definition our
diverse place that's they have to be
diverse but you know there's many
examples in the historical historical
record where empires are not necessarily
more equitable or nicer places to live
for most of their population and so I
think this sort of helps show that
diversity you know even though what we
call diversity isn't really what were
what we're driving at and so maybe what
you want to do is sort of find replace
all the instances of diversity with
equality and that is something that we
should be looking at in this whole first
part of the talk wary we're thinking
about bugs in the tropics is not really
the right way to go so let's kind of
shift gears a bit and try to think about
equality um so I wanted to talk instead
before we really dive into the math here
sort of in an
from other parts of society so I
actually think that a PI data and you
know the scientific community and stem
as an element of the broader society is
doing relatively well that's not to say
that there aren't problems and there
aren't issues but if you look at other
parts of society so let's take the field
of dance for instance and we'll go
through this they have much much more
significant issues along diversity
inequality than we do so if you look at
dance you know many many children go
into dance and the overwhelming number
of them are female especially in the
this childhood range and this is
anecdotal because hard data doesn't
exist so I apologize about that once
dancers hit college age most people drop
out of dance at that by that point but
those who are in Tremayne it's roughly
seventy percent female and thirty
percent male so if you go to your
average dance department at a university
this is what the sex split will be and
so that's probably representative of the
people actually interested in dance as a
profession and then if you go to the
young professional stage sort of by
virtue of the way the system is
constructed there's about as many male
roles as female roles they have sex
parity in dance this is a real
phenomenon if you go to your average
like young professional junior developer
dance company right there 5050 um but
then you get up to the senior level
right senior dev choreographer level and
especially among the big names big-name
choreographers are overwhelmingly male
even though they started opposite right
so you know we might talk about a
pipeline problem like dance has a
pipeline problem and they're really only
beginning to even acknowledge that this
is a problem so the whole culture is
very different right they don't talk
about it
they and if you talk to them about it
they they tend to say there's nothing
that can be done so depressing but but
but that's what it is and so it's
interesting because even though there's
sort of gender parity or sex parity at
at various levels I don't think as a
whole you could call the field of dance
and equal system so that's an important
point okay so we've got someone thinking
about equality we've got a couple a
couple more motivating questions that we
could ask so the first one is can two
individuals be equal and I think in the
United States if you look at this from a
legal perspective the answer is yes you
know we're all almost citizens our peers
to other citizens we kind of don't care
we legally wash over any quality issues
for the most part especially in criminal
cases but in a measurement sense we're
actually trying to measure things right
II people are not necessarily equal
there's tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of axes on
which you might measure someone and so
we're not necessarily equal per se we're
all sort of special snowflakes and so
that you know you can kind of and then
the LA just sort of says well we don't
care about that averages over everything
okay so this is a high dimensional
problem but that's not really what we're
talking about right we're not talking
about individuals we're talking about
populations so can two populations to
two groups of people be equal I think is
the more important question if you're
trying to engineer a system and I think
the answer is yes but like we talked
about with diversity you're going to
need an underlying metric to measure to
see if you can be equal if see if two
populations can be you but luckily we
have some tools right we already sort of
saw some of them we saw some with
diversity before and so a colleges have
again thought about this quite a bit not
as much as the diversity issue but
there's a related quantity that they
is if they eat alternately quality
quality or evenness and you can define
equality as the measure of a cute
ordered diversity / the diversity of a
lower order are and so if you do that
for any qnr you get a new quality
measure and that's a something that you
can just go out you know again it's like
one Python expression it's not
particularly hard and you could plug in
the numbers if you had the data and so
the most common one of these is just
equality 0 1 which is equal to again
just the entropy the exponent of the
entropy divided by the number of groups
or partitions that you have that's
equality sort of makes sense right
you've got a bunch of groups of people
how evenly are you spreading out the
resources that you might have
alternatively you can define the
inequality index is just the inverse of
equality so that's useful if you want to
think about inequality in this sense
again so this is an ecologist definition
economists have separately derived their
own inequality measures right as you
might expect economist to do so there's
a steal inequality he'll entropy
inequality a measure and they derive
this term and it's not it's only a
couple jumps to realize that this is
simply the natural log of our of the
inequality that the ecologist define so
all of these quality measures are
actually even though they come from very
disparate parts of science they sort of
focus down on a couple of information
related measures that are not that are
that are not difficult and are sort of
art the bread and butter of what you
might consider data science you can
generalize the inequality measure the
feeling equality if you want and so if
you can get a inequality of order Q so Q
G just as the natural log of inequality
0 q divided by your
order so okay not super not super hard
okay so we have a measure or we have
something that we can go out and and
plug numbers to into but when can we say
that two populations are actually equal
right so these are constructed systems
society as a constructed system and so
you've got to have some kind of
engineering tolerance on this right
floating-point precision doesn't seem
like the right route to go for your
quality measure so you you want some
value here within the question and you
know this kept me awake at night for
many nights is like what is that value
what are those tolerances that you allow
on your any on your equality that you
can just call it a day and maybe you
can't do any better than that and so you
know what is that threshold and so
there's a couple ways to approach this
problem and think about it and sort of
maybe the first one to that comes to
mind is if you look at loading and
pulling tolerances right they typically
publish errors in the range of three to
five percent these are big societal
measures maybe three to five percent is
appropriate I sort of feel that that's a
little high actually and so that's not
something that you know I would be kind
of uncomfortable at five percent in
equality was what we were aiming for but
especially if you look at economic
measures uh you know like pender or
gender pay gaps and things like that
maybe a better place to look is the
minimum change the Federal Reserve can
make to the interest rates right so if
you look at this the minimal value the
Federal Reserve can adjust interest
rates by is 25 basis points or 0.25
percent right so maybe you could say two
populations are equal if they're average
incomes are within you know a quarter of
a percent of one another and you like on
a societal wide scale for hundreds of
new
people you might not be able to do any
better than that with any or you might
not have any more fine-grained control
just a suggestion I don't know what the
right answer is this seems like a
reasonable number but unfortunately when
I say these numbers they're actually
simply a statement of the mean right and
that's problematic right so suppose you
had to two populations with the same
mean but different standard deviations
inequality I argue is actually also
living in the variance or the standard
deviation right so you care about these
higher order moments of your normal
normal distribution so just imagine
right maybe this is in come along your x
axis that you're distributed along well
if you've got a higher standard
deviation these people are the richer
folks and they have an incentive to keep
everyone below them at the status quo
and so when they keep everyone below
them that disproportionately affects the
population with the lower standard
deviation and so this is one of the
reasons why you can see sort of a
driving force if this was the case to
have even though your means are the same
to within 25 basis points you might
really want to fiddle with the standard
deviation significantly and so this is
again a problem so what are the
engineering tolerances for this the
variance what what should your variance
be so if you have your means equal what
is your how close to your variances need
to be to be equal and so to tackle this
one strategy is maybe you could look at
the entropy of the normal distribution
which happens to be a function of the
variance and look at the critical point
of that and if they were if those two
things if you got your variances to
within that you would be able to say
your populations are effectively equal
in an engineering design system kind of
way
okay so if we go through and plug in the
numbers right so we set H equal to zero
and then we solved for Sigma squared and
we do that we get a variance that needs
to be within about six percent and a
standard deviation that's within it
within about twenty five percent and
that you know so okay so that those are
some real numbers you can look at so
does this hold up so this is what those
two population curves look like again if
your means are the same and your
standard deviations are off by twenty
five percenter your variances are all
right by about six percent and I think I
think that this does these populations
do more or less in you know in an
engineered system these look effectively
equal there you know there are some
differences you can notice up at the top
and sort of along with sides and things
but they'll probably wash out maybe you
could do better maybe you could do worse
but at least this is a value a target
value that seems reasonable for defining
the quality end goal for some of these
for some of these metrics that you might
look at you know and there's probably
other suggestions out there this is just
one so i think the the point one of the
main points of this talk is that if you
have a strategy for minimizing equality
differences you should be empirical
about it right that should be a
data-driven strategy and if it's if you
don't have the data to show that that
strategy works then you should treat
what your suggestion is is an experiment
and start measuring things while you're
running the experiment and see whether
it works or not and that's the way to
engineer the system engineer broad you
know large-scale societal systems to be
more equitable you but you actually have
to go out and measure things or have
data and so just looking at a couple
case studies here so the CDC recently
put out an LG p lgb study of high school
students
and sort of found significant
differences between lgp students who
were bullied and who had forced sexual
intercourse over their heterosexual
counterparts and this was published in
The New York Times last last week but
this these graphs come from the CDC
because the New York Times use pie
charts but um so let's dive into this
data a bit more right so these are
horrifying differences in the mean if
you look at this on a basis versus 25
basis points right there just the the
differences just in the mean just blow
this out of the water and that's really
troubling but what I really want to know
is I want the time series right are
things getting better or things getting
worse do i change my strategy do do we
do what we've been doing and that's the
data that i want to see but if you go to
the cdc it turns out that august 2016
was the first time they've ever
published such a study so you if you
only look at the CDC data you have no
idea whether this is these are good
numbers or or bad numbers or horrifying
numbers or moving the right direction
you're not moving in the right direction
and so I argue that this is actually a
classic data science problem right
there's poor and missing data multiple
data sources that we might need to draw
from and we need to synthesize
information to be able to pull out these
equality metrics that were actually
interested in and so and the CDC hasn't
really done it for us and you know
there's some other depressing aspects to
this like so in the future like the New
York Times probably won't report on this
because it won't be news anymore ah and
then you know the CDC definitely does
have the ability to gain longitudinal
data for subpopulations but you know for
whatever reason for these equality
issues they they have not historically
so okay so that's sort of the sad case
study
of the on the brighter note if you look
at gender parity at conferences but for
in particular at pycon and in this
particular case measured by the percent
women giving talks at PyCon which
happens to track with the percent women
attending PyCon but these numbers are
easier to find the growth rate has just
been absolutely staggering over the past
five or six years here and this is led
by Jessica mckellar and if you talk to
her in person or on the internet she
will repeatedly tell you that the
strategy that she used to increase these
numbers from 1 percent to forty percent
in the course of five years was direct
engagement with individuals she goes out
she talks to people she encourages them
to apply she makes sure that they apply
and they get talks okay so this is a
strategy where you can think that that
might be a successful thing to do and
then if you actually go and measure the
numbers it turns out it's a successful
thing to do interestingly enough this
also coincided with a pike on i believe
around 2011 2010 also or maybe 2012
implementing a code of conduct but if
you talk to Jessica mckellar the code of
conduct is not explicitly what a draw
drew these diversity numbers it's the
fact that you talked to people and maybe
that's implicit but it's not a direct
driving force ok so I think there are
some cases that are under studied in
this community and there isn't empirical
evidence to that really says that they
work or don't work and these are areas
which we could actually use a lot of
help and reflection trying to acquire
evidence one way or the other that they
do work so I think just to start out
things that almost certainly work that
almost certainly are effective at
creating a more equitable system uh but
just for which there is no data
our codes of conduct for conferences I
think these things probably help it make
sense that they help but we don't you
know we should be empirical about it and
we don't have sort of we haven't done
this study we don't even have Jessica
mckellar level numbers on from the
previous slide to suggest that codes of
conduct that conferences are effective
the other thing that likely works but i
think is even on it slightly more shaky
ground or codes of conduct for projects
these might help divert they probably
help diversity it makes sense again that
they would and for reasons we'll talk
about on the next slide you know there's
but there's just not like the evidence
there's not this body of evidence that
suggests that they actually help or that
there may be the most effective way to
help or any number of things and so and
then finally things that might
questionably work uh-uh but again for
which there's no data are activities
like public shaming and calling people
out who break you know or conference
organizers etc you know but people even
at sify this year there were people who
there are people who advocate public
shaming as a valid diversity strategy to
increase equality but my question is
like where's the where's the evidence
for that just like fred these are there
to where is the evidence that the any of
these things actually actually works ah
ok so the legal standing for projects is
actually a really weird thing if you
haven't looked into the legality of an
open source project unless you're part
of some broader organization like numb
focus or you have a foundation like a
Python softer foundation or the linux
foundation around you you don't really
have legal standing so it's sort of a
loose collection of individuals and that
doesn't sound particularly satisfying in
a lot of ways and you you kind of have
to put this juxtaposed to things like
businesses and universities that do have
in a legal sense at least work
protections and ethics codes and thing
there there are ramifications if you
break uh if you break the law or you
violate a code of ethics and I'm not
claiming that these are always the best
solution or that they always work I
think there's a lot of evidence to
suggest that they probably aren't they
are imperfect but at least they exist
right with your average open source
project on github or bitbucket or
whatever you don't even have workplace
protections you don't have the
university standing behind you it was
just like someone on the other end of
the on the other end of the tubes that
could do anything it could be a bot even
you have no idea right so so there's you
know it elisa exists so and to follow
this up right i think uh codes of
conduct as a as a legal tool are even
less strong than a software license
especially for project so for projects
right for conferences it's kind of clear
like the conference organizer has
allowed you on the premise like subject
to these rules that are posted prior to
the you attending so you know that
there's nothing to do there but you know
you're kind of in the wrong if you break
the code of conduct but on an open
source project that there's just a bunch
of other individuals you know there
haven't been these high profile and i
actually couldn't find any in the case
law when i went and look I couldn't find
any cases where someone was sick sood
sood successfully or unsuccessfully
unsuccessfully for a code of conduct
violation that's not to say that they
don't work but they don't get to the
legal level and they they're a legal
standing as documents might not be much
more than sort of bites on a hard drive
somewhere not really they don't really
have the same kind of gravitas that a
license has and so you know if this is
concerning oh well I think it should be
concerning right like there's got to be
something that you can do and maybe that
something is joining them focus but yeah
but maybe not that's probably not a
solution for everybody so there's kind
of other issues to work out here
haven't been fully solved yet okay so
take a moment breathe right uh the point
of this talk was to show that these
problems are not intractable right you
can approach diversity and equality
issues from an empirical basis and
they're not like impossible problems and
that isn't even that hard really then
the purpose of this talk was really
meant as a call for action to obtain
diversity data that is the missing piece
now right we have these metrics what we
really lack is the information and the
data to start proving or disproving that
certain strategies work and/or to run
the experiments that we might need to
run to engineer a more equitable system
okay so that I'll just like to conclude
on some final sort of data points here
that says I do believe strongly that
strategies to affect equality should be
based on evidence right where we r pi
data right we should be believed in the
data and we should acquire data and that
like we're the experts here this is the
thing that we should be doing we have
these metrics so we can measure things
you might not agree that these are the
best metrics but at least we have a
place to start from there's a whole
corpus of literature that you can go out
and look at and you know it would be
night it would be good to have that
debate I think about what the best
quality metrics are I've just shown you
the ones that I think are probably the
most successful um you know and again
raw data might be hard to come by I
think there are organizations and places
that we could look at in companies and
and other institutions that might be
able to serve a role helping us acquire
the kind of diversity data that we would
need to start showing things about you
know whether whether codes of conduct
are an effective strategy whether we
could just do this direct outreach
and those kinds of issues where we have
mechanisms for acquiring data uh so
let's go out and acquire it and then if
you don't have data to back up a
particular strategy if you have no idea
whether something works or not you
should default to the highest state of
empathy so if you don't have any data
supporting your strategy should always
try to do the thing that gives the other
person or other group the benefit
benefit of the doubt and tries to you
know maybe they had a bad day or maybe
maybe you know some they just didn't
know and so I think this is a this is an
aspect this is kind of the rule of thumb
that I have that says well yeah this is
why you should do codes of conduct but
maybe you shouldn't do public shaming
without evidence okay and so I really
the purpose here is to encourage you all
to go out and obtain diversity data and
i'll leave it there thank you very much
questions does anyone have any questions
outstanding talk did you look at all at
maybe like the health industry medical
because it seems as if they're looking
at underlying populations and how
treatments work yeah yeah so I I didn't
I didn't look at how things other than
the CDC in this particular case I think
that's a rich mind to you know go and
take your pick axe to but I didn't look
at it I was just trying to figure out if
you had that data what what would you
how would you analyze it right because I
think that's where people get hung up
it's like well I have all this data now
what do i what do I do with it okay so
like we don't even have the data in a
lot of cases right and you know I
personally benefited from
Jessica's outreach you know probably
five go back five years and the one on
one you know it had that multiplier
effect that we talked about yesterday
you know it wasn't just a few but we
wouldn't know that it works if she
hadn't collected the data that's right
absolutely yep and so yeah I think what
Jessica did was amazing because she
collected the data and now basically
every conference should be doing this
right and we can show that we that every
conference should be doing this because
it works even though it's a lot of
effort it's worth the effort so we keep
coming back to that we've got systems
that we can use to meditate to evaluate
the data once we get it that we need to
be collecting data what do you think we
should be doing to collect data what
kind of data should we should we be
collecting and you know how do you think
we should go about doing that yeah so
that's an interesting question so it
really depends what you're looking at
but I think so let's just take the
example of conferences for the first
part I think that all conferences should
be running you know entry and exit
surveys and that that should that data
should be anonymised and put online
somewhere you know it doesn't have to be
that hard but if you had that and it
would be self reporting and then people
could like other people who are
interested in this problem could go and
analyze it whatever that way they want
and try to you know make a case one way
or the other so that's the kind of
conference attitude I think it's harder
for when you talk about projects
especially with codes of conduct and so
maybe what you could do you're going to
have to this is kind of more social
science ii but you'd have to assemble
sort of a large body of codes of conduct
incidents over a wide variety of
projects and maybe if you had a way to
you know because no one's tracking this
we know there are like you know if a
project had a code of conduct violation
i'm going to pick on sin pi for this
moment so there was a there's a person
on the sin PI community who was
effectively asked to leave eventually
because he or he or she was very like
naked
have in the community for very for
various reasons and this happens all the
time but it's not like that information
went anywhere right it didn't go to like
a code of conduct like violation
repository but then you can do text
analysis on later like maybe there
should be something like that I i I'm
yeah that's the kind of data that you
might be looking at for these kinds of
things and you know mate and that way
you might be able to say well recited
the code of conduct and then like that
was an incident but you know good luck
trying to get a project to do that so
yeah it's impractical but yeah for
looking at equality equality systems
evaluating historically yeah can we go
back to earlier groups like early
Christians early Protestants it said or
a look at diversification well the you
know it and evaluate how the early the
early quality systems played out yeah
see you you can uh yeah you can
certainly go back to historical systems
and try to apply some of these measures
I don't think there's any problem there
I think there are two main issues that
you might run into if you're trying to
engineer a current system based on
historical data and so one is that you
don't necessarily know where your
historical data is exactly right the
error bars are huge like you don't
necessarily know the wealth of a
particular population group in you know
50 ad or 50 c e right like to any to
anything more than ten percent so that's
one issue so if you're trying to
engineer a system to 25 basis points
like ten percent errors just like
terrible and then the second issue is
that if you like listen to historians
and talk to historians or classicists
you should always be very wary of taking
things from history cultural context
from history and applying it to modern
times and so I think that is or even
cross culturally today it's very
difficult to sort of apply the cultural
norms of one society to and compare
against our society I'm not saying that
it wouldn't work
I'm just saying it would be it'd be an
interesting historical exercise it
wouldn't necessarily help us engineer to
do systems what we really need are
today's data well in that case wouldn't
engineering a system today not
necessarily apply to the future
population in the future cultural norms
yeah that's right it wouldn't yeah so
we're only kind of in a you know you
have to continually do this stuff and
it's it's a generational thing you got
every 5 10 20 years you know the that
culture is going to shift and you have
to shift with it so thank you so much I
know there's a lot more questions but
we're gonna keep going and you'll be
available for the rest of the day right
yeah yeah it's a question coming chat
with me about this stuff I'd be happy to
talk to you yeah this is amazing this is
the kind of thing that human beings are
supposed to be doing measuring stuff and
just debating about systems right so big
round of applause thank you so much
doctor